are you following the protests only cuz
my wife watched she watched the women's
rally uh-huh she did watch that which
was which was very inspiring I was like
10 minutes and then it was just like a
hundred thousand people in the rain
agreeing with each other
it was just like three hours are you
ready to play yes I said are you ready
yes we're all on the same page here can
we go inside
yeah then Madonna crushed it
Madonna comes in wearing a beret so you
know she's in a rebel mood right the
absolute king and queen of just steering
it back to your own music catalog drops
a couple of f-bombs threatens to blow up
the White House because she knew FoxNews
would be like is Madonna a terrorist and
then she seamlessly goes into some of
her back catalogue and you know throws
out a few tunes you know to get some
iTunes money was hilarious it was so
brilliant so you couldn't say bother you
that she's saying are you impressed at
being in this business it was so perfect
she did you know she did everything but
be like and Trump wants to put a wall up
between here in Mexico I believe there's
no borders between countries border line
this is my first protest ever you could
kind of say it's like I'm a virgin she
should have gone through the whole thing
I can't imagine the money she made off
of that it was all and then all the
celebrities in the background sort of
listening doing this and then
famewhoring off each other like no no I
love how your mind works I love how your
mind works each other and at the end of
the day they were still going to men
that's what I didn't like about it like
you still had to go down to the guy's
house and be like hey knock it off they
should have been like a guy networking
handing out business cards right you
build websites I want to do this I think
the way to get people in power to pay
attention is you don't go to him you
kind of like have a meeting over here
then that freaks them out like what's
going on over there yeah and then they
come over here right
you don't walk up to their house
that's a weak move
you